Prime Minister ham Duke thank you so
much for being here with us on DW news
you've taken over Sudan at a historical
moment the country is facing many
challenges did you have any doubts about
wanting to take this role
not not doubts about ours it's not a
business it's not really a personal wish
this is a wish that is responding to a
call of duty I did not have a single
doubt at responding to that knowing so
well it is full of challenges it is
dynamic it is nonlinear you get it right
today you have problems and heritage
tomorrow taking this job was a response
to the calls of the nation people who
have managed to give the world one of
the probably very rare moments of change
but ever in our history something that
we equated to great moments in nation's
history equal to the fall of the Berlin
Wall
years or centuries back probably the
French Revolution that momentous change
created the environment for me and many
others to help building a new nation
it's a dawn I was in Sudan back in April
at the Syrian in front of the military
headquarters and I saw many young people
they were full of expectation and hope
from the government that eventually
became your government do you feel like
your government is living up to their
expectations this is what make a stick
the hope the expectations about us
about the change about the government by
our people we never promised that we're
going to do this on our own it's a
shared responsibility we rise and fall
in this process together with one
conviction that we have two options
either to succeed or succeed and I think
we're moving in that direction but a lot
of young people that I've spoken to in
the past couple of days say the things
that they went to the streets for like
basic living conditions including bread
these things have not been fulfilled so
do you think that the young people's
expectations were too high no their
expectations were never too high it's
normal expectations by any government is
people but also I'm sure they're they
understand they appreciate we inherited
a daunting challenge a legacy of 30
years you cannot undo it overnight but I
think equipped with that conviction and
determination with our people working
together we had no doubts that we will
be able to address this and overcome
these challenges what do you tell to
young people who perhaps are feeling
impatient with the delivery of actual
result results to their lives one thing
let us work together to address these
issues expectations is one thing but let
us address these expectations together
our interests are aligned we don't have
different interests from this
expectations the same so let us join
forces in addressing all these
challenges together so then is being run
now under unique cooperation between
civilians and military how is the
cooperation between these two sides
because it hasn't always been smooth has
it yes this is also another feature of
the uniqueness of this Sudanese
experiment we are proudly propagating
this across the world and calling it a
Sudanese model which is a partnership
between the civilian and the military to
build democracy being solid foundation
for democracy this partnership is
working it is not free from challenges
there are so many challenges but I think
there is a determination on both sides
to make it work and we're doing that
precisely if you look at the region
around us the failures in many places
because I think they were able to
establish an accord that would allow
such partnership to move the country
forward we know were experimenting with
it we know you know there is no
transition that is smooth transitions
are always messy nonlinear and I think
that in itself what makes it a very
interesting experiment to be part of do
you trust the military side of your
government do you trust them absolutely
I do because some young people that I've
spoken to have said this military has
been involved in the oppression and at
some point even the killing of so many
protesters I do appreciate the views
that are expressed by our young people
remember these are young people who were
subjected to all kind of oppression you
lived through that and you know it in
the streets and all this for years for
decades so that's why they have disputes
but I think gradually we are building
this partnership together none of this
equation two sides of the equation
will be able to move on their own
to build this new nation appreciate
those views but we are working together
to address them let's turn to the topic
of the the you know the clearing of the
sit-in in June and the people that were
killed on the streets a lot of them
believe that the rapid support forces
were involved in this attack when will
these people see justice because so far
some say the results just have not been
up to what happened to the
protesters on the streets I'm sure you
know so well and the constitutional
document which is guiding this
transitional period has a very clear
undertaking that will establish an
investigation committee so let us not
jump to conclusion that investigation
committee formed from very respected
lawyers and people in the legal field in
Sudan they started their work over three
months now and they're doing their work
let them do their work and produce the
report you recently requested that UN
peacekeeping forces be deployed in the
hold of Sudan why did you do that
why is the UN needed now in Sudan
actually let us put this in into its
proper context we did not just walk up
one day and say we want the UN to come
to the country the UN is there I'm not
calling it the UN is there under Chapter
7 meaning that is if there is anything
that you could closely call it loss of
sovereignty is what is happening today
what we are calling for is to move the
UN from chapter 7 chapter 6 which would
allow us to express our wish and if you
could call it anywhere dictate on the UN
on our priorities this is where we would
like to create an opportunity where we
tell the UN this is what we want I'd
like you to come do one two three four
on our teams the whole country approach
is an idea we discussed in our National
Committee for a number of months what it
tells us in the past the UN intervention
in Sudan was compartmentalized it is
therefore it is a Blue Nile it is a new
mountains South Kordofan and all that I
would like to see when we see whole
country approach is addressing the
challenges and the issues and the
requirement and objectives of the entire
transitional period
this certainly has some agenda which is
of national debt of whole country when
you talk about elections I'm not going
to have them in there for could be the
whole country Constitution conference it
will engulf the entire country the
process itself we would like to enlist
the support of the UN in those processes
that of a national nature that's why we
call it a whole country approach that
support could be providing one advisor
could be providing technical support
take an example the election today we
would like to embark on a process that
will conclude this transitional period
with an election the UN has accumulated
experiences technical and otherwise
across the globe support on addressing
issues of election systems an election
system that will provide us with an
opportunity to represent all our people
the one could provide that so it's not
about entrusting this entirely to the UN
the funding of the elections the UN has
accumulated various experience in
generating resources and funds to
support the elections so it's only
perfect and we are part of the Union
it's not like another body you were
something that's coming from somewhere
let's turn to the topic of the hour the
possibility of former president Alma del
Bashir to appear before the
International Criminal Court will he be
sent over to the Hague the idea of
justice need to be served to the maximum
satisfaction of the victim is something
was well articulated in the
constitutional transitional period
document we will definitely uphold that
there are four ways of addressing this
the ICC is one of them ICC itself has so
many levels it could be an ICC in the
heck could be an ICC
planned court that is Sudan or in the
region transitional justice issues of
Truth and Reconciliation compensation
individual and community we are not
going to rest until the victims those
victims to be satisfied that just is not
only being perceived but actually being
served and that's how we see it
from what I understand all options are
now open you still haven't decided
whether it be in The Hague or in Sudan
or in a Regional Court of course this is
something you know the the announcement
of this was part of our peace
negotiations and I think this is
something we will I want to tell you one
thing
any person who committed atrocities
criminal financial we will have to be
trained and that's our bottom line we're
working on rebuilding your judicial
system and all that and we hope to have
a credible independent judicial system
Sudanese let's talk about Germany and
your visit to Germany the past couple of
days have been quite historic in Sudan
Germany relations concretely what how
can Germany help Sudan in the meeting
with the Chancellor Her Excellency
Angela Merkel yesterday provide an
opportunity for us to reflect discuss in
depth or interest or mutual interest for
that matter and we agreed on concrete
areas that German will work with us
supporting us whether it is the economy
the energy sector vocational training
mining agriculture so many hours and
we're very delighted
this is signaling a new beginning of
this relationship which has very high
promise and we look forward to this
cooperation that would also allow other
partners and Friends
and nations to follow suit what the
gentleman is doing
you mentioned the economy Sudan badly
needs foreign investment what are your
plans to attract foreign investment to
Sudan your government's plans Sudan is a
very rich country we don't want to live
on handouts but so rich in the sense
that if we were able to create the right
climate meaning getting it right in the
legal sphere independent judiciary
system respect for property rights and
all that and we are working on this
creating a one-stop shop for investors
creating an environment where a serious
genuine investors come work with us
pay their taxes and be able to
repatriate whatever profit they make and
we're creating that environment and
we're very confident we'll get there
Sudan is surrounded by many countries
that have seen change because of popular
uprisings and many of them have
descended into chaos
Sudan different absolutely Sudan is
different in the sense that we are in
this middle as you mention it whether
you call it the sorry all in the center
of Africa Sudan change is unique in many
respects is peaceful
it has great hopes for the entire region
I call it getting it right in Sudan has
a strategic impact and effect you can
imagine the spillover effect in the
entire region but in the north to our
west south and east what we would like
to see our friend and partners working
with us making this a success story it
has all the right ingredients of making
it a success in the sea of misery and
conflict around us that's why it is a
unique experiment unique in nature and
all that and let us get friends and
partners what
with us the world and in that particular
part of the world is looking for success
stories that were absent for a long
period of time Sudan is giving that hope
is giving that opportunity let us grab
it let us work together on it and make
it the real success story that will
change the face of that birth tuft Prime
Minister thank you very much for your
time
oh it's gonna be very much thank you